but let's talk about elizabeth warren
you brought it up you brought it up
she proposed attacks on the wealthy u.s
billionaires would have paid a combined
114 billion dollars for 2020 under an
ultra millionaire tax that senate
senator elizabeth warren
proposed and the way the bill works is
anything you have 50 million
net worth anything above it it's a two
percent tax on your current wealth
anything above a billion
is a three percent tax on top of your
billion that you would owe based on all
the wealth
uh american billionaires at the end of
2020 a decade of wealth on them
would fund about three quarters of
presidents joe biden's 1.9
trillion dollar chronovirus relief
packet so they're kind of trying to get
the money back for that a separate
analysis of the university of uc
berkeley which
again janet yellen estimated that the
tax would generate
three trillion dollars in revenues over
the next 10 years an interesting study
done by uc
berkeley amazon jeff bezos would have
paid 5.7 billion dollars in wealth
taxes in 2020 bezos would have paid two
elon musk would have paid a 4.6 gates
would have paid 3.6 zuck would have paid
3 billion
thoughts on the wealth tax she's tried
it before
i remember that so like you have to have
buy-in from your own party
and at last check the democrats were no
longer a party for the people
they've long since sold themselves out
to corporate sponsors so
they have to be on board where did you
find fresca
you want a fresco you want one yes i
will get you a fresca
that's amazing oh yeah fresco but
fresco's a
it's a it's a really hard to get your
hands on
it is but we have connections with this
we got guys we got here from columbia we
got a fresco
laura laura and so sam and laura she'll
be here yeah you're gonna get your egg
sponsor like in five minutes because
because they're going to trade you for
fresh podcast is sponsored by
no look she's tried this before
the the figures sound like they're big
but to a lot of these
multi-billionaires they're rounding
errors and
for anybody who's offended by it they're
just going to leave just look at what's
happened with
new york and new jersey and the people
who have moved to the great state of
florida
because they're offended by bad tax
policies
these things never work out the way they
seem and but it they make for really
good sound bites
they they do do they though do they when
she goes out there and saying like i'm
sitting there wondering saying
okay you do wealth tax on your next
campaign you need wall street to fund
you what are they going to say to you
what are you talking about exactly that
that's what i'm talking about that's
something she's not going to get buying
from her own party it's almost as if
she's permanently disqualifying herself
of ever running
and winning anything but that's her job
and she'll get re-elected
she'll be in the grave and she'll still
be in office but not not at the highest
level
you talk about what she's doing right
now of course yeah yeah that makes sense
what are your thoughts on it i guess my
question is well number one the tax code
in america is
ridiculous i mean i i it's the most
complicated thing just
you make a hundred grand a year to do
your taxes it's very difficult so now
you're talking about
these people who are worth billions and
billions of billions in the tax codes
and the loopholes and the
tax write-offs and this and that you
know i'm i'm the more and more i hear
about
flat tax obviously ross perot simplified
simplify it
keep it simple the more and more like i
think about it
i'm agreeing with adam he's very smart
today with his life
all right but here's here's where i'm
gonna flip it and not be so smart
this is why you get the comments that
you get sometimes where people come
after soyboy mafia but go ahead tell us
you know what the thick skin all right
bro
i got thick glasses things he hasn't
shaved for a while so he's got an even
bigger layer of protection
though flat flat tags but by the way we
just found out today that a young
rudy giuliani and a young adam
would never be in adam's league right
isn't that what it is i would never date
a young hot julia
never yeah i would like to know the art
i would like to get in hot in the same
sense i would like to hear our
people we were having a conversation
before the podcast put a young rudy
giuliani picture up
oh my gosh okay we're gonna do that
we're gonna do this yeah
here i am putting my glasses i'm trying
to talk taxes by the way
back here you heard this adam thinks
he's a dime okay adam
adam thinks there aren't many men better
looking than him in the world but go to
a young rudy giuliani
look at that yeah look go too
look at that right there that's a great
guy okay zero to ten what are you
running for three come over here to 12
he's not a 12 but he's at least a seven
you say
okay let's you called him a good looking
guy and i questioned you wait a minute
what is good looking to you
i think i think he's a good looking guy
look at that i think that's a good look
what's wrong with that look
at the what about the one on the left
right there kai go down you're going
down you're going down and stop bop
right there what about that picture
which picture the one where his face is
falling off and melting buddy he is how
old in that picture that's right now
you think you're gonna look good but
here's my point like you think you're
gonna look like this
beautiful looking handsome face you got
going on i gotta say you guys still have
your hair so
you have no idea the point that i was
making about giuliani because obviously
you took shots out of it
people want to hear about my thoughts on
taxes they can't wait to hear my
thoughts on taxes i get it
my point with giuliani is here we go
three words
fall from grace this was america's mayor
we're talking about what a mess
new york city is we're talking about
cuomo we're talking about de blasio
danielle mentioned why can't we get
someone like giuliani back and i said
yes
i said yes he was the man in the 90s
cleaned up the mafia
cleaned up the streets took the trash
out 911 he was america's mayor he was a
hero
and now he's at 11. and he was and now
he's here now he's a punchline in a
borah movie his face is leaking he's
doing press conferences in front of four
seasons porno shop
think about it he's had a fall from
grace think about the two men who were
on the pile
the pile in downtown new york debbie
and giuliani yeah whose legacy is intact
who didn't say a
word through all of trump's
administration and obama and obama he
totally graceful his legacy is probably
better now than it was when he left
office when he left office he was
wait a minute are you suggesting the
strategy is to disappear
and don't do anything no no that was his
strategy
and by the way i mean we we had bush at
our event a year and a half ago and i
got to tell you when we had a hundred
people that took pictures with him this
is pre-coveted
you know what was the most common thing
everybody said to him they said
you know president bush i got to tell
you i thought you were the auntie i
thought you were
i thought you were the devil i thought
and i i've just fallen in love with you
today oh my gosh i didn't know there was
this this this
he got 63 of the hispanic vote in the
state of texas when he
when he ran for governor the second time
63 percent of hispanics
solid right uptight white boy yeah yeah
so
he got a lot but he he would have a beer
with a man of the people yeah
no longer he would have a beer with you
but was true yeah
no longer because he changed his life
after you know an incident i think
what he did okay so you like his flat
taxes that's what you're saying
back to that i think what george w bush
clearly his biggest mistake was
um you know invading iraq and west's
weapons of mass destruction
essentially you know there's free music
change i mean he's a puppet for a dick
chain
you'll be even smarter damn give me a
fresco
um and what did he do
since he's left office not do anything
stupid
giuliani opens doors to just like
where can i open the stupid door and he
just walks right into it you know i
i had a i had a friend of mine that i
gave this advice to one time
i said you know you know what your
biggest challenge is he says what's
what's that
i said uh when there's crisis i never
worry about you
he says why i said because you're always
going to come out of it 100
you're going to come out of it i said
but when there's no crisis and
everything's good i worry about you he
says why i said because you freaking
create crisis oh is that his deal
you don't like to be in peace giuliani
is a freaking wartime guy he needs that
he needs the drama yeah but that also
means sometimes when you get into a
street fight you're going to get your
ass kicked and they're going to show
that highlight of a knockout
and your name is tyson getting knocked
out by buster douglas that's going to
happen this is what happens with
giuliani
politicians need a hippocratic oath
first do no harm if there's nothing
going on shut your mouth
yeah and that's what george w bush did
he said about the point i was going to
wrap up with
yeah but some retire on time
some continue playing basketball and
their legacy looks bad
there's timing in retirement like bush
disappeared legacy got better
right yeah some stay in the mix too long
and then there's too many opportunities
screw up because and then there's tom
brady hello
yeah seven which is and by the way he's
still continuing so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye